[Music]
that's me Ruby McGuire residential
advisor give it to me
I'm just so proud but times you know
it's like okay
the heck's top male eighteen to thirty
fair-skinned circumcised farmer's tan
possibly a member of the nudist
cooperative
[Music]
Hey that evidence belongs to campus
police not some nosy co-ed with a knack
for solving head-scratching mysteries
officer Roy McCoy veteran campus cop
we're practically partners we're not
partners this is cheese Greer if I'm not
mistaken Mel stood in the hot noonday
Sun I would check if there any cheese
based events happening on campus today
Ruby I don't need your help okay I've
already got an expert compiling a
psychological dossier on this perp
what's good my Peebles Professor
Appenzeller a shameless unicyclist who
thinks he's an undergrad so I'm thinking
we got a freshman on her hands maybe had
one too many four lokos know what I'm
saying and until we find this kooky
crazy swingin dong we're implementing a
strict 5:30 p.m. curfew my events night
the 2017 stargazers back at all you
haven't replied to my paperless post I
can't be for heterodyning with students
it's against school code well let me
help you know what Ruby just be a kid
huh
yeah buy a pizza drink a coke yeah I
gotta go
you stay work with me take his advice
okay stay woke
the nudist cooperative inhabitants of a
darling craftsman home on fraternity row
yesterday afternoon an individual
fitting both of your descriptions was
seen gallivanting around campus in his
birthday suit was enough we stay inside
our property the mid-century modern
craftsman in the style of Frank Lloyd
Wright what were you doing yesterday
afternoon hosting an event fondue fest
you can set up team until we were
attacked
[Music]
some thugs broke into our party
it was so traumatic that our only female
member quit Carroll evenly bronzed skin
if a dyed-in-the-wool nudist but the
real culprit has a farmer's tan these
people are innocent any idea who could
have done it the Zeta ain't a theta boys
are pissed off I dropped their fret they
left this bike latke on our lawn
[Music]
Arnie Humperdinck Oh Barry Natori tomato
masochist
with a flair for interior design feel
the silk it's very soft Arnie is the
president of the Zeta ADA theta
fraternity their house burned down after
an unfortunate hazing mishap involving a
can of their harry pledge and a lighter
they now reside in an abandoned jo-ann
fabrics on the outskirts of town
your student I thought you were an admin
or something like that what were you
doing yesterday afternoon at 3:00 p.m.
fraternity business maybe a fraternity
prank some light streaking perhaps hey
no talking in the furniture looks like
he's about to give out what part about
Herman Miller Aeron chair don't you
understand
vote please excuse us hope your
toothbrush is clean because we got some
floors and figure out what were you all
doing yesterday afternoon
oh we were just try to scare scare who
talk to me Ottomans don't talk yeah Roy
Roy I've got a hot lead on the streaker
case Ruby I solved the case I got proof
it was the newness the whole time stay
right there I'm coming over what are you
talking about the streaker came back
this morning roll tape
what's that blemish on this backside a
birthmark or maybe a dope henna tattoo
doesn't matter they drop this this is
too easy
well I thought you'd be happy curfew is
over the bad guys are suspended in Zeta
ETA theta gets on campus housing say to
every theta is getting the nudists house
I know but deal with actually it is not
lit at all
Roy I think this is a copycat copycat
why do you say that because we listen
little girl the case is closed
Roy McCoy is here on the campus he's
happen can I give you some advice
College goes by so fast
I think you should spend less time
sticking your nose and everybody's
problems and more time making memories
with your friends
assuming you have friends whoa c24
laughs look I thought I know be sure
go to the wall
boom Newport well boots it danced hola
Oh
don't boo like that
[Music]
Hey hi my early Oh No
others will be arriving shortly
thanks for coming oh well this is this
is on my Patrol oh okay uh what are you
looking at uh nothing much really I'm
still learning just sort of scanning the
skies well you got a quality us right
there what's that
horse constellation I figured it out
have you
hey it's aqualia s-- roy
[Applause]
[Music]
security footage clearly shows this
morning streaker with the Zeta Edith
theta crest of a stallion tattooed on
his derriere the derriere belonging to
our knee humble dingleberry he's been
sitting on a ring cushion after getting
his painful but tattooed but why would
he streaked because he wanted to frame
the nudists by placing a pamphlet at the
crime scene Marcus the nudists burned
down that house now him and all of his
nudie booties live in a California
craftsman relax son take a seat okay
couldn't have been them they were at
fondue fest 2k 17 Arnie's just a copycat
yesterday's streaker was someone else
entirely it was Professor Appenzeller
[Music]
little hot outside for a scarf a home
slice my bubble date that's no hickey
those are the same cheese blisters that
the nudists had meaning that you were at
fondue fest TK 17 filling your naked
belly to the brim with your favorite
panache doused in piping hot career and
afraid he'd be found out by his psych
101 student he fled from the crime scene
if I was naked why just one through
campus
because he lost his life piece but I
wasn't trying to do anybody harm I was
just trying to hang out be cool with the
guy is know if you want to relive your
20s that's fine but shame on you for
incriminating those poor nudists look
I'm on another whodunit in the can maybe
I'll finally be able to sleep tonight
maybe the faces of the men I've locked
away won't haunt me when I close my eyes
maybe maybe til next time
[Music]
[Music]